we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
uh i got a very funny voicemail about
how was i even able to enjoy my vacation
given that i didn't have with me all of
the different products and services from
our sponsors take a listen to this i get
it's a joke but i like it anyway david
sir
how were you able to enjoy your vacation
without access to your chill sleep cube
sleep system helix mattress or nebby a
shower head i know
yeah i had i had to deal with
um actually the mattress at the place i
stayed was was really good but yeah i
had to deal with the total inability to
cool my mattress
with the chilly sleep product that we
have as an advertiser
um i didn't even have blue chew that's a
joke by the way guys but that is one of
our advertisers i didn't have my blue
blocks glass i didn't have anything on
the trip and somehow i still had a great
time okay very good we have a great
bonus show for you today first and
foremost i'm going to address head-on on
today's bonus show
why has the bonus show been a disaster
from the technical standpoint on monday
tuesday and wednesday the explanation is
a sort of simple one and i'm going to
even ask for help with it
also
delta airlines which never refers to the
delta variant as the delta variant they
always call it like the 16217 or
whatever the whatever the number is they
don't want to call it the delta variant
because they're delta airlines which is
sort of funny delta airlines is going to
be charging unvaccinated employees an
additional 200 per month for health
insurance why well because they've made
an actuarial calculation and they've
determined our cost for unvaccinated
individuals over time is going to be
higher
are people going to quit delta airlines
we'll talk about it on the bonus show
and then lastly we have an update it is
not going to be a recommended third dose
at the eight month mark it's going to be
a recommended third dose at the
six-month mark and of course this is
leading people to ask
am i going to need a booster every six
months
um and also raising questions about why
don't we have a booster that is tailored
to delta
rather than the same old shot from 2020
and we were going we're going to address
all of those different questions on
today's bonus show
get instant access i would love to have
you on the bonus show really
sign up at joinpakman.com it takes only
seconds you can use the coupon code
myhippa
myhippa of refrain from many anti-vaxx
republicans myhipa
use the coupon code myhipa to sign up at
joinpakman.com you will get a huge
discount and oh people i got a bunch of
emails saying david what interviews are
upcoming uh we have a bunch of really
good interviews upcoming tom hartman is
going to be joining me soon i also am
excited many people recommending vincent
racconello i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly one of the hosts of the this
week in virology
uh podcast
he is a virology professor at columbia
university brilliant guy from the
standpoint of virus
he will be joining me and we've got a
bunch of other great guests upcoming so
i'll talk about that more early next
week but for today grab that membership
i will see you on today's bonus show or
sadly otherwise we'll have to wait until
tomorrow to be together again